My first master was a kind man.
My mother and I had a happy life.
One day, my master sold me to Squire Gordon.
"You're a beautiful horse," he said.
"You have a beautiful black coat."
"I shall call you Black Beauty."
I learned to carry my master on my back and pull a cart.
The coachman's name was John.
One night, John had to take a letter to a doctor.
The squire's wife was very ill.
"Wake up, Beauty!" he said to me.
He jumped onto my back.
"Run as fast as you can," he said.
"Mrs. Gordon is very sick."
"She needs a doctor."
I ran as fast as I could.
We soon came to town.
John woke up the doctor.
He gave him the letter.
"Ride Black Beauty," John said.
"He is tired, but he will run as fast as he can."
The doctor was heavier than John, but I did my best.
I carried the doctor to the house.
Then I lay down.
I could not breathe.
I was in pain.
I was very sick for a long time.
Mr. Gordon often came to see me.
"My beautiful horse," he said to me.
"You saved Mrs. Gordon's life."